[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 4 mars bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 78 26
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition l'écologie au coeur des
programmes des candidats aux élections
municipales parmi les propositions celle
de construire des éco quartiers dans les
villes il s'agit d'un label accordé par
l'état qu'est ce qu'un écoquartier
comment est attribué cette dénomination
éléments de réponse à suivre et gymnase
avant le premier tour du scrutin comme
chaque soir dans le journal l'actualité
de la campagne présentation des listes
en lice à guyancourt nous suivrons
anne-claire frémont en opération de
tractage aux clayes-sous-bois et puis
invité jean-louis mais teulet candidat
du rassemblement national à plaisir et
puis le paris-nice bien maintenue après
malgré et malgré l'épidémie de
coronavirus la course la course cycliste
s'élance dimanche depuis plaisir c'est
la onzième année consécutive que la
compétition par des yvelines le
programme des films à l'affiché
également à retrouver à l'espace
philippe noiret c'est aux
clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
l'une des premières résidences
intergénérationnelles d'île de france
inaugurée à guyancourt elle a été
inaugurée hier ouverte depuis le début
de l'année cet ensemble immobilier
appelé coucou nadj propose 84 logements
allant du t2 au t4 des habitations qui
s'adapte aussi bien aux familles qu'aux
seniors particularité de ce concept
il offre des services qui favorisent les
échanges et la solidarité entre les
résidents aurélie rose pour les
interviews dont toutes ses résidences
on trouve une maison des projets
c'est-à-dire un local participatif dans
lesquelles des gens vont partager
échanger créer des activités des
ateliers et donc dans toutes ses
résidences on a un lieu maison des
projets on a un gestionnaire animateurs
qui va accompagner le lancement
l'impulsion du projet résidentiel
collectif le gestionnaire animateur lui
est là quatre jours par semaine pendant
deux ânes deux années et pendant ces
deux ans il va construire selon
l'intérêt il est là dès l'entrée des
lieux et avec chacune des personnes il
va mesurer l'intérêt de chaque individu
chaque ménage pour participer ou pas
dans l'actualité également le
département des yvelines présente son
premier bilan carbone il a été dressé
par la collectivité avec
l'accompagnement d'un cabinet de conseil
depuis le deuxième semestre 2010 9 les
huit principales sources d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ont été dévoilées
achat de fonctionnement amortissement de
la voirie est en tête ce sont les
collèges qui occupent les trois
premières places déplacement des élèves
responsables de 21% et des émissions
énergie des bâtiments ou encore repas
scolaires pour 16 et 15 % le département
à intégrer cet enjeu environnemental au
coeur de sa stratégie pour améliorer ce
bilan carbone les propos recueillis par
michael et demi d'euros on va tous faire
pour qu'il y ait la quantité la qualité
puisque vous évoquez les collèges on
veut surseoir au programme de
reconstruction ou de construction de
neuf collèges
de façon à en faire des collèges
écologique et en particulier en
structure bois donc prendre du retard
mais nous nous efforcerons néanmoins de
financer ces neuf collèges c'est vrai
que ça risque de nous coûter un peu plus
cher mais on fera cet effort et
d'écologie il en est question pour le
premier tour des élections municipales j
- avant ce premier tour c'est le
dimanche 15 mars est la notion d'éco
quartier revient constamment dans les
idées des candidats les régulièrement
cité pour les villes on parle de ce
dispositif avec nicolas d'andry bonsoir
bonsoir grégory de la rédaction de tv 78
alors qu'est ce qu'un écoquartier et de
laurier un écoquartier c'est un label
que peut obtenir un projet d'aménagement
qui prend en compte les principes du
développement durable
à l'origine de cette appellation la loi
de programmation relative à la mise en
oeuvre du grenelle de l'environnement
c'est un texte qui date de 2009 et à
l'article 7 alinéa 3 ans on regarde on
voit que l'état encouragera la
réalisation par les collectivités
territoriales d'opérations exemplaires
d'aménagement durable des territoires
il mettra en avant un plan d'action pour
inciter les collectivités territoriales
à réaliser des écoquartiers avant 2012
en fournissant à ses collectivités des
référentiels une assistance technique
pour la conception et la réalisation des
projets concrètement si on regarde dans
le détail qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière ce
label le label ecoquartier est basé sur
quatre dimensions on retrouve les trois
piliers du développement durable qui
sont le cadre de vie et l' usage pour le
social le développement territorial pour
l'aspect économique et l'environnement
et climat pour l'écologie dernière
dimension la démarche et processus pour
la gouvernance du projet alors ses
dimensions sont déclinés en vain un
engagement par exemple on retrouve
formaliser et mettre en oeuvre un
processus participatif avec les citoyens
mettre en oeuvre les conditions du vivre
ensemble contribuer à un développement
économique local équilibré et solidaire
ou encore favoriser les moyens de
déplacements collectifs et alternatifs
comment fonctionne cette labellisation
nicollin seules les communes et les
intercommunalités peuvent lancer la
demande du label pour un projet
d'aménagement d'un quartier différentes
étapes pour cette labellisation le label
étape 1
c'est la signature de la charte éco
quartier l'étape 2 correspond au
lancement du chantier l'étape 3 la
livraison du projet et l'étape 4 peut se
faire trois ans après l'étape 3 pour
tester et évaluer la vie dans
l'éco-quartier mais pour terminer quels
sont les exemples d'écoquartier dans les
yvelines et bien au total 18 projets
sont labellisées ou encore en cours de
labellisation labellisation regarder ces
quelques exemples dans le département
unique projet classé en d'étapes 4 à
l'heure actuelle c'est le projet des
molières aux mureaux une candidature
vient d'être déposée pour le projet du
secteur peintre médecins du val fourré à
mantes la jolie en est à trois
aménagements déjà livré on retrouve le
quartier du bel air à saint germain en
laye en cours de chantier labellisé
étape de deux projets à
chanteloup-les-vignes le quartier rouget
de lisle à poissy ou encore la zac
renard de saint cyr l'école
enfin plusieurs projets d'aménagement
ont ou vont obtenir le label un mort pas
le vélib ou à plaisir le quartier de la
remise à voisins le bretonneux et on
retrouve même des communes rurales comme
le perray-en-yvelines ou encore son
champ merci nicolas de nous aider à y
voir plus clair la direction à présent
engluée en cours pour la suite de
l'actualité de la campagne des élections
municipales quatre candidats vont
s'opposer dans la ville pour ces
élections et grégory pape françois
morton olivier paréja et rodolphe barry
présentation avec michael et demi
d'euros à guyancourt ville de 29000 65
habitants quatre candidats s'opposent
quand il pas peut-être de liste de
nouvel élan à guyancourt ce pharmacien
de profession habite la commune depuis
2012 est également représentant d'élèves
l'homme politique se lance dans sa
première campagne lors de ces
municipales 2020 nous sommes lancés il
ya un an nous avons commencé un travail
de terrain aller à la rencontre des
habitants de guyancourt avec un premier
questionnaire suite à ce premier
questionnaire nous avons identifié les
grands thèmes qui interroge les gluants
courtois sur ces grands thèmes nous
avons construit des ateliers
participatifs
nous en avons fait la synthèse pour
rédiger nos programmes deuxième liste
ensemble agissons pour but en cours
menée par rodolphe baril l'homme
politique de 58 ans a notamment été
scolarisé au collège paul eluard qui a
été maire adjoint voisins-le-bretonneux
de 2008 à 2014 et conseiller
communautaire le début de l'histoire en
fait c'est
c'est un certain nombre d'amis durant
courtois avec qui j'ai échangé et fort
de mon expérience et mon écoute tu a le
profil pour être tête de liste est ce
que tu voudrais pas être notre tête de
liste pour monter un projet sur
guyancourt donc voilà ça c'est fait
aussi simplement que ça donc je mets à
profit mon expérience d'ancien élu
l'ancien maire-adjoint d'anciens
conseillers communautaires au profit des
gluants courtois troisième liste
décidons ensemble à guyancourt une liste
participative menée par olivier paréja
un ingénieur de 54 ans qui habite le
quartier du village
cet homme politique à la sensibilité
écologique vie à vue en cours depuis
c'est ce qu'on m'a confié d'être tête de
liste en fait pour nous ça veut surtout
dire porte-parole d'un collectif donc ça
veut dire que c'est pas nécessairement
celui ou celle qui va tout décider mais
plutôt quelqu'un qui est mis en avant
parce que le fonctionnement actuel d'une
liste d'une municipalité est comme ça
mais ce n'est pas notre fonctionnement
naturel nous on voudrait faire quelque
chose de beaucoup plus collectif de où
tout le monde peut participer quatrième
et dernière liste guyancourt pour tous
ceux 2020 une liste menée par le maire
sortant de la commune françois morton
l'homme de 50 ans a été auparavant
premier adjoint au maire en charge de
l'éducation de la jeunesse et de la
politique de la ville sur le plan
professionnel il est enseignant
spécialisé
j'assume parfaitement ce bilan ce bilan
il est encore une fois apprécier un
propos pour rencontrer très
régulièrement et au quotidien l'ensemble
des années des habitants de guyancourt
je sais qu'ils apprécient effectivement
les actions et les réalisations mises en
place durant ce dernier mandat c'était
déjà le cas dans les mandats précédents
mais il s'avère que je n'étais pas élu à
l'époque donc je mais j'assume
totalement ce bilan et on en est
particulièrement fier à plaisir on l'a
appris avec le dépôt des listes
officielles cinq candidats sont engagés
dans la campagne bonsoir jean lui mais
teulet
bonsoir messieurs canal et vous êtes la
tête de liste de rassemblement pour
plaisir vous faites partie des quatre
candidats dans les yvelines avoir été
investi par le rassemblement national la
formation je le précise est aussi
présente dans d'autres villes par le
biais d'alliances précisons qu'à plaisir
une liste front national avait récolté
en 2014 9,25 % des voix une liste
conduite à l'époque par le conseiller
municipal d'opposition
aleksandar nikolic est pour vous
jean-louis medley vous avez été engagée
au sein d'un conseil municipal pendant
dix ans
en région parisienne dans une autre
ville de la région parisienne pourquoi
vous engagez cette fois ci à un plaisir
tout à fait donc j'ai été autrefois
effectivement conseiller municipal à
l'opposition aujourd'hui nous voulons
servir plaisir nous avons remarqué que
dans la ville malheureusement depuis
huit ans ce n'était plus du tout le même
climat qu'autrefois nous avions un
ancien maire joël regnault où on pouvait
les le voir il était dans la ville on
pouvait discuter lui poser des questions
on avait des réponses plus ou moins
satisfaisante mais au moins on avait une
vie municipale sur plaisir aujourd'hui
on a du mal à rencontrer notre mère on
la voit que dans des réunions publiques
et lorsqu'il y à une réunion souvent on
nous impose
on va dire des projets dans une réunion
de concertation finalement on n'est pas
écoutés donc on est très insatisfaits de
l'ambiance et de la dérive que l'on a
depuis huit ans la réunion qui a été élu
jusqu'en 2012 et joséphine coleman ce
berger lui a succédé à l'est d'ailleurs
candidate à nouveau pour un prochain
scrutin est ce que la liste qui est que
vous présentez aux prises roi est ce
qu'elle est similaire à celle qu'avait
présenté le front national en 2014
elle est renouvelée aujourd'hui alors
bien sûr il ya un renouvellement
puisqu'il ya des personnes qui ont fait
un chemin depuis huit ans qu'on me qui
ont évolué qui ont déménagé ou qui je ne
sais pas ne s'intéressent plus au
contraire d'autres personnes
s'intéressent aux affaires municipales
donc bien sûr c'est une liste qui a
évolué en huit années tout à fait
qu'avec le nouveau visage à un triptyque
pour votre programme sécurité identité
et proximité que l'on va détailler dans
un instant sur le plan des projets alors
vous dénoncé un manque de concertation
finalement de la mère joséphine coleman
ce berger mais sur le plan des projets
quel regard vous portez sur ce qui a pu
être mené sur le dernier mandat
sur le dernier mandat
en fait moi j'ai des il ya plusieurs
projets sur lequel on n'avance pas ça
fait huit ans que j'alerte la mairie sur
certains projets et on n'a pas avancé
il ya des sujets qui bloque et puis il
ya des sujets qui avance
je trouve que nous avons à plaisir
malheureusement bon il ya une politique
effectivement de limiter les dépenses
qui est très bien mais sur certains
domaines c'est parfois trop juste il
donc il faudrait vraiment une écoute des
habitants et offrir une qualité de vie
ce que nous n'avons pas forcément ou pas
suffisamment sur notre ville alors si on
détaille votre programme sur le volet
identité la mesure principale c'est
préserver le cadre de vie à plaisir
alors vous proposait notamment de
dynamiser le centre-ville limiter la
bétonisation ça fait partie de vos
propositions de quelle manière vous
comptez y parvenir alors dynamiser le
centre ville c'est quelque chose qui
faisait déjà
enfin qui était déjà criant des dès
l'arrivée de madame le maire en 2012
donc à rien n'a été fait en huit années
alors il ya une rénovation qui a été
enclenché du centre ville oui il ya des
effets d'annoncé effectivement nous
sommes sûr plaisir sur une politique
d'annonce une politique de communication
et finalement nous ne sommes pas écoutés
nous n'arrivons pas à nous faire
entendre par exemple nous avons des
problèmes sur le stationnement à la
guerre plaisir grignon
ça fait plusieurs années que j'en parle
que j'ai demandé un parking sur cette
gare et c'est un projet qui n'a pas
avancé
en huit ans il a fait partie de vos
propositions ça le parminou tout à fait
effectivement c'est une question très
importante pour nous puisque de nombreux
à la fois des plaisirs wacom des gens
extérieurs ne parviennent pas à se garer
pour prendre le train alors qu'on parle
aujourd'hui d'écologie de prendre les
moyens alternatifs de transport
ben en fait il n'ya pas une offre de
parking satisfaisante sur la gare de
plaisir grignon
alors soit volet sécurité vous voulez
augmenter les moyens de la police
municipale développer la vidéoprotection
aussi lutter davantage contre la
délinquance notamment au quartier du val
hibon qui a été touchées par des
phénomènes de violence des affrontements
notamment avec la police comment vous
comptez
l'ugtt est justement contre contre cette
délinquance il ya la violence
et puis il ya aussi les stupéfiants il
ya des trafics de drogue il ya beaucoup
de choses qui ne vont pas alors c'est
vrai qu'on a on rénove 7 ce quartier où
cet éco quartier
mais on oublie finalement le fond une
politique de fond et non pas une
politique d'apparence une politique de
fond c'est déjà dire dans ce quartier il
ya de la violence
si on met plus de 60 millions d'euros
dans ce quartier on peut quand même
consacré une partie de cette somme à la
sécurité si vous vous promenez dans
plaisir je pense que vous n'aimeriez pas
être agressés ou à être en danger dans
notre ville donc je pense que les
priorités sont pas toujours bien défini
actuellement et qu'il faut offrir aux
plaisirs oies et au plaisir oise une
sécurité pouvoir se promener et être
heureux dans notre ville et le dernier
axe et la proximité alors vous souhaitez
notamment rapprocher les quartiers il
est une proposition par exemple de créer
des navettes internet interquartiers par
mois ça ce sont des pistes
oui pour rapprocher davantage les
plaisirs roi ce n'est pas une piste
c'est une certitude
on voit dans de nombreuses villes des
navettes interquartiers et c'est très
utile pour les habitants les personnes
âgées qui ne peuvent pas conduire ou se
déplacer aimerait ses navettes
l'interquartiers ainsi que les personnes
avec handicap
peut-être aussi des enfants et il faut
savoir qu'il ya une modification du
réseau de bus qui a mécontenté la
population et malgré tout on a un
nouveau dispositif de réseau de bus qui
ne qui n'est pas fonctionnel qui l'autre
qui ne convient pas beaucoup de
personnes et le projet est passé malgré
des concerts des fausses concertation
avec les habitants
il y avait beaucoup de personnes
remontés contre ce projet et malgré tout
il est passé un dernier mot sur la
question de la santé plaisir et est
classé en zone d'action complémentaires
on sait que c'est un problème qui va se
poser à plaisir et que de nombreux
médecins qui partent à la retraite et
qui seront non remplacés vous souhaitez
vous par exemple la création d'une
maison médicale
c'est ça à plaisir oui oui tout à fait
monsieur canal est donc une maison
médicale c'est indispensable
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi l'équipe
municipale n'a pas prévu n'a pas géré
cela depuis huit ans on savait que les
médecins était haché qui deviendrait
beaucoup départ en retraite
voilà on a vu venir on a laissé faire et
il s'est rien passé je ne comprends pas
et après on nous nous sert de la
communication de la publicité pour nous
dire que la ville est très active
or là on voit un grand une grande
carence un grand défaut de l'équipe
municipale
donc nous voulons vraiment changer les
choses à plaisir
en conclusion on pourrait dire que nous
ce qu'on veut c'est pas une politique
spectacle pas une politique de
communication
on veut vraiment répondre aux attentes
des habitants et leur offrir une qualité
de vie et on retrouve votre agenda de
campagne comme celui des autres
candidats sur le site internet de tv 78
points comme merci jean louis met l'aide
est revenu en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes la tête de liste de
rassemblement pour plaisir une liste
investie par le rassemblement national
et sont également en lice pour le poste
de maire à plaisir l'édile sortant de
joséphine coleman ce berger l'ancien
adjoint aux finances patrick l'inter et
les conseillers municipaux d'opposition
annie joël prix ou admis ainsi que jamel
niati dans la ville voisine aux
clayes-sous-bois cinq candidats
également anne claire vraiment en tête
de liste les clayes-sous-bois c'est vous
s'est rendu au marché de la commune le
week-end dernier à la remise son
programme aux habitants manon varaldo
c'est dans ce lieu local au marché des
clayes-sous-bois que la candidate anne
claire frémont sapeur pompier de métier
va à la rencontre des habitants
est-ce que vous avez une autre oui oui
vous l'avez des questions le
développement du commerce de la ville et
sa vie économique sont des enjeux
importants pour la liste les
clayes-sous-bois c'est vous notamment
pour cette ancienne vice présidente de
l'association des commerçants de la
ville
en tout premier lieu il faudrait engager
un manager de commerce local qui
travaillerait en concertation avec les
commerçants la ville et les élus
permettrait de redynamiser la ville
grâce à des animations grâce à une
diversité de commerces locaux un peu
plus présente
et puis travailler vraiment concertation
dans le cadre de la mise en place d'une
nouvelle association des commerçants
éventuellement je pense que les
animations fait revenir éventuellement
une brasserie un pub ou un commerce de
bouche serait un véritable atout pour la
commune
parmi les autres propositions du
programme un projet le tutti passeur
d'art s'adonne possibilité à une tranche
d'âge d'enfants pendant trois ans
d'avoir un instrument de musique
gratuitement et des cours de musique
gratuitement son temps scolaire et
périscolaire et qui permet de monter un
orchestre municipale en partenariat avec
les associations puisqu'en parallèle
nous souhaitons de cet orchestre
municipal en faire un orchestre
intergénérationnel et si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas on est tous les
dimanches tous les jeudis au marché il
ya des réunions publiques elle la
prochaine réunion publique est organisée
à 10h30 samedi 7 mars à l'école henri
proulx et pour refermer cette page
dédiée aux municipales ce soir sur tv 78
radio sensations nouveau débat entre les
candidats émission consacrée aujourd'hui
au scrutin à saint-germain-en-laye 7 à
20 heures sur notre chaîne ou sur la
fréquence et 80 18 points 4 fm pour nos
confrères de sensations yvelines c'est
la première grande course européenne de
la saison le 78e paris-nice démarre
dimanche première étape au départ de
plaisir le lendemain les coureurs
s'élanceront de chevreuse et la onzième
année consécutive que la course au
soleil par des yvelines on en parle avec
notre consultant cyclisme alors que
momcilo tombe sur tv 78 yens dujarrier
bonsoir en soirée vous êtes également je
le précise licencié au club de vélizy
champion du monde master de vitesse
individuelle sur piste un paris-nice
maintenu malgré l'épidémie de
coronavirus plus de 200 cas en france
quatre morts au moment où nous
enregistrons cette interview ce qu'il
fallait maintenir la course
on verrait bien sûr bien sûr enfin alors
moi je suis je suis contre tout
comment prise de panique prise de
panique ynwa la wii coronavirus ou pas
coronavirus il faut il faut continuer de
vivre il faut il faut continuer bien sûr
qu'il faut faire attention bas donc
lavage des mains plus régulièrement et
puis et puis
continuons la course quelques
perturbations forcément déjà arnaud
démare le français de la team cofidis
qui ne participera pas au paris-nice il
est confiné avec une partie de son
équipe à abou dhabi en raison de
l'épidémie de ducobu de 19
arnaud démare on le rappelle qui avait
gagné la première étape en 2017 à bois
d'arcy celle de 2018 aussi au départ de
chatou on peut s'attendre comme quelques
perturbations sur sur cette course mais
comme comme tout événement alors arnaud
démare c'est fdj et pato fille dit c'est
pas grave alors j'ai raté un j'ai raté
quelque chose dans ce mercato mais met
donc bien sûr il va y aura des
perturbations pour pour tous il bien sûr
que tout le peloton qui était abou dhabi
est resté est resté cloîtré à l'hôtel
depuis maintenant une presque une
semaine je crois parce que même le tour
d'abou dhabi n'est pas fait les
dernières étapes
elles ont été ajoutées l annuler donc
voilà c'est du cas par cas c'est il faut
faire des examens et puis à partir de là
bas si on est sûr qu'on est con on est
tranquille on peut on peut on pourra se
déplacer c'est aussi un paris-nice
endeuillée avec la mort on l'a appris
hier de nicolas portal directeur sportif
de la team ineos ex sky est décédé à à
40 ans d'une crise cardiaque il avait dû
arrêter sa carrière cycliste en 2009 à
cause d'une arythmie cardiaque un
coureur qui était l'archétype on peut le
dire du coéquipiers prêts à se sacrifier
pour pour le team leader un très grand
un très bon coéquipier tout à fait et
surtout un
1 comment un directeur sportif qui qui
je trouve est très très bon en
communication
j'apprécie beaucoup le personnage parce
que ben malgré les critiques qui peut y
avoir aussi monsieur rich et skyblu
ineos il arrivait toujours à passer et
il a toujours prôné sont enfin le fait
qu'ils sont que ce soit une équipe clean
et voilà j'espère que
que l'avenir nous fera savoir qu en
effet il avait raison et qu'il n'a
jamais menti
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est un des
ces très jeunes qui qui choque le milieu
cycliste parce que voilà 40 ans et c'est
quand même pas normal
et puis je trouve que c'est un mec était
qui était sympathique je ne connaissais
pas j'ai jamais rencontrée je me disais
crimée et voilà dans les interviews j'ai
toujours trouvé sympathique très sérieux
dans ce qu'il faisait mais mais voilà
parfois on pouvait sentir qu'il gardait
un certain retrait mais assez assez
déconneur et ouais moi j'ai apprécié
j'apprécie bien son personnage et j'ai
bien j'aime bien l'équipe sky malgré
malgré tout ce qui peut être dit autour
autour de bons terminé sur la première
étape de cette course dimanche l'étape
de 154 km entre plaisir et plaisir une
boucle dans les yvelines avec des
difficultés à franchir on pense aux codé
minul de neauphle-le-château c'est ça
les principales
alors pour pour un peu ton professionnel
c'est anecdotique
maintenant ça va quand même être une
belle étape j'ai regardé la météo les
prévisions météo qui ne sont pas pas
idéal c'est d'entendre de l'entente de
mars sur sur la région parisienne
il fait beau samedi malheureusement il
ya moins bien ça moins bien dimanche
moi ce que j'apprécie sur sur ce
parcours c'est la fin de la fin de
parcours qui fait un petit escargot et
donc les gens qui voudront voir le
peloton plusieurs fois en étudiant bien
la carte pourront couper et allez allez
allez voir les coureurs à plusieurs
moments et aussi les deux derniers
sprints qui sont en moins de 35 kg elle
est à moins de 35 kilomètres de
l'arrivée les deux derniers sprints et
ils sont rapprochés de 13 km ça va être
aussi assez sympa de d'essayer d'aller
d'aller d'aller voir les 2 et 2,2 et
donc ça à faire de ce spectacle une fin
d'étape qui risque d'être très très
rythmée par contre difficile pour les
échappés je pense à cause des ces deux
prix d un esprit enfin de ces deux
sprints pour pour le classement à points
qui vont être sur la sur la fin de
parcours
je pense que les échappés vont êtres
vont être compliqués recours aux gens de
l'arrivée et puis il ya cette dernière
côte à quatre kilomètres de l'arrivée
qui qui de toute façon ne fera que cette
étape n'est pas fait pour les pour les
sprinteurs mais plutôt pour les
puncheurs
un dernier mot un pronostic sur ce
paris-nice 2019 on sait qui a gagné
bernal dernier vainqueur de ce paris
nice est aussi dernier vainqueur du tour
de france julian alaphilippe le français
qui voyez-vous l'emporter c'est très
difficile puisque ses débuts saison
julian alaphilippe et n'est pas en
grande forme sur les sur les premières
étapes la première course qu'il a pu
disputer je pense qu'ils né au ça va
être compliqué avec la perte de 10 des
acteurs sportifs dont on a parlé à
richie porte juste avant de la penderie
cola portal pardon par contre y voit
bien des découvreurs type richie porte
des coureurs de l'éducation first ou ou
de grosses structures mais voilà des
coureurs que l'on voit plutôt un second
couteau sur le tour de france à la voile
a brillé sur sur sur ce paris-nice
voilà ça va être
j'ai pas pu avoir la liste des engagés
puisque assez compliquée avec le corona
virus mais voilà je pense que des
grosses structures très très l'équipe
australienne scott mitchell tonnes scott
par exemple voilà ceux qui ont des ddd
très bon coureur risque de pouvoir tirer
leur épingle du jeu plus facilement je
pense départ donc ce dimanche à 11
heures première étape au départ de
plaisir le lendemain elle les coureurs
s'élanceront de chevreuse merci à yann
dujarrier et j'aurais pu préciser que
vous êtes le consultant cyclisme de tv
78 aller pour terminer le programme des
films à l'affiché à l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret des clés soit
nous vous proposons le film d'animation
en avant en sortie nationale et à partir
de 6 ans qui vous raconte l'histoire de
deux jeunes frères elf qui cherchent à
découvrir un monde meilleur dans leur
monde imaginaire
nous vous proposons également le très
attendu dernier clint eastwood le cas de
richard jewel et les images vagabonde en
partenariat avec l'association
contrechamp un festival qui met l'accent
sur les femmes rebelles avec jacky braun
ehouman at war ce lundi est également
les invisibles et thelma et louise
pendant deux semaines les deux lundi
prochain nous aurons également rebelles
pour le jeune public
enfin nous vous invitons à venir la
semaine prochaine pour l'avant-première
de pinocchio retrouvez toutes ces
informations sur le site des clayes sous
bois et à très bientôt à l'espace
philippe noiret
[Musique]
la fin de ce journal belle soirée sur tv